hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to live their leave I'm not
100% sure how to pronounce it but
there's supposed to be a very good
horror game in the same style as the
original amnesia the Dark Descent and
that doesn't mean that it's an exact
clone but that does mean that it's
probably dark creepin hallways with lots
of close encounters with horrible
monstrosity zuv all kinds I can't wait
for it because it's been a long time
since we've had a like a really good
horror game oh my turn my name is Robert
dawn and I was born in London
I used to write this sentence countless
times in my childhood years and I
remember father desperately trying to
teach me calligraphy he was persistent
as a teacher yet always caring a father
when I grew up I became a journalist
allowing me to escape his parental grasp
to live a life on my own a whole new
world had opened itself up before me and
I took the leap without a moment's
hesitation times were tough back then
yet I was enjoying every single moment
of my new life had to offer well
wonderful for you Robert dawn oh it was
then that I felt it for the first time
it is said that you only get one chance
to live your life to the fullest and
break free but when my father passed
away unexpectedly he left behind
insurmountable debt thrusting me into
the abyss my zeal was tempered in my
mind crowded while cleaning up his
personal belongings old memories of him
came back to me as if waking from a deep
slumber and as I touched the yellowed
practice sheets I wondered how long it
had been since our last writing session
together underneath the sheets I found
an envelope and inside it was a letter
faded with time which I carefully
unfolded what was written inside shook
me up completely what I considered to be
my life my whole existence was shattered
beyond recognition
No okay weird that day I lost everything
as if it had all been part of a
theatrical shadow play according to this
letter I wasn't even born in London but
somewhere far from here the unfamiliar
postal stamp revealed at least that much
frantically I searched the attic but no
matter how hard I tried I couldn't find
anything else about my past this letter
must have been the only thing that my
father had kept perhaps he had secretly
wished for me to find it after his
passing as if seeking Redemption was I
really looking for the origin of my
story was I just chasing a dream a cheap
excuse to abandon my old life in search
of a challenge something or somewhere to
test my mettle just a few of the many
questions that occupy my mind is this
little boat rocks drifting slowly
towards my final destination
well I'm music crescendoed at the right
time and I love I love me a good musical
score like I can't live oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] dude righto what happened I'm
assuming something bad happened and I'm
on the verge of death hello it me from
other side are you there Oh holy [ __ ]
okay I'm so ready oh I'm so excited
Oh what's up oh hi what is that is that
a statue or a dildo I can never tell
okay okay
oh hello hi oh [ __ ] I thought that was
footsteps hang on it's too early - okay
by Odin's beard oh jeez
okay that's a little peculiar oh and it
looks good too out was that through my
hand
I'm so tickled I'm so excited
what's happened yep now through my hand
all right
ouchies ouchies Kaboodle's I better pull
that out probably Thank You orchestra I
needed to know that really hurt okay
let's get into it then ah yes
okay a little bizarre mossad to walk
around okay so what is this ha oh [ __ ]
my dear friend when the time is right I
will personally make the final
arrangement for his departure the
arrival of the supply boat is due next
month so you shall have plenty of time
to make preparations before he arrives I
trust you will keep your word and will
see to it that he will get a proper life
far removed from the pain and sorrow
that awaits him here I seek no
forgiveness for what I've done and
couldn't manage to do but I do hope that
one day everything will be remembered as
if only us a dreams mist take care of my
little boy Robert ah so my father wasn't
actually my father my father was an
adoptive father oh that's pretty
oh that's pretty oh look I get a lantern
oh it's Chloe oh wait no oh I thought I
got that oh I thought that was gonna be
mine I thought I was gonna have it for
mine oh man I'm so excited and I don't
want to make too many comparisons to
what amnesia was because it would be
unfair to this game to say it's only
just like amnesia and I want this to
treat this game as if it's its own
entity but that I'm just going based on
what I saw on the reviews and so I I
don't mean to be unfair draw a different
conclusion oh I can eat
oh I'm recovering Huth oh good the
mining company made an offer on the
house yesterday
I hear they need better access to the
port and I wish I could just take it and
leave but we don't have anywhere else to
go my parents are long past dented even
if they weren't the villagers up the
hill are getting sick too the bodies are
piling up in the streets this is the
safest place we can be right now I mean
you could hop on a boat and maybe get
the [ __ ] out of here oh man why did
someone leave that knife in that rap
all righty then hello oh it's so cool
can I pick things up ah dammit no
physics-based okay alright hello I
burned the last of his possessions today
just as a doctor suggested he told me
that if I don't show any of the symptoms
within a week they will allow me to get
my son back
the postman told me the rumors he had
heard about the sickness the people said
it came from the mines although I doubt
it originated there probably aliens that
said Greek on it does it loo sorry sorry
about your ancient Greek pottery
I just shattered ooh dark in here hello
ah yes hi whoa okay ah that doesn't look
good that looks that looks patently bad
that looks like a barrel from half-life
I don't want to know what's over there I
must face reality my husband is gone and
we don't have enough money left to last
another year now the winner is right
around the corner and with the roof
leaking I will have to start the repairs
this week it won't get fixed by itself
when our eldest son turns 12 next month
he'll be strong enough to help with
picking olives this year after that I'll
have to figure something else out I just
have to everything will be all right
we'll make it no it's kind of sad Oh
more Greek spaghetti in a can I'll just
eat the can hole shove it straight down
my gullet I ain't need to worry about
nothing else I can digest aluminum as
the same as the best of them oh boy Wow
okay so I'm guessing those are the
entrance to the mines and this house is
nothing [ __ ] [ __ ]
well alright let me just get my heart
started back up again okay I think I'm
okay Wow
why the hell was that there what could
that have possibly prevented I have no
goddamn idea but there's another one
over here already covered with blood
from another unfortunate soul that
stomped his way heavy-footed over this
way anyway
into the thick of it I go again watching
out for more bear traps heart attack
bear traps walk up to a ladder to climb
it you got it buddy boo all right so
what is this ah [ __ ] off Jesus just eat
the eat everything in sight and get
smashed on by everything jeezum oh I
thought that was gonna be another one
okay this is this some swatches here BG
zooms but Jesus
oh good lord bejesus okay I don't know
what this did if it did anything at all
huh boom okay is that good
hubba okay looking on the ground trying
to be more mindful of everything I'm
probably gonna hit another goddamn bear
trap sticking everything I do I remember
I was playing dead by daylight with the
boys and uh I kept running into some
goddamn bear traps and I obviously knew
were there but that footage was one of
one of the many footage that I lost
unfortunately which is very sad because
getting my new recording setup up and
running has been a bit of a a bit of a
beyotch but I'm getting it
oh okay oh so that opened up oh I didn't
know I needed to go this way around whoo
all right so far so goo I haven't seen
the miners for the last two days I
wonder what's going on I'm grateful for
the silence but the sudden
disappearances make me feel
uncomfortable
the postman hasn't shown his faces month
either I hope he's all right
he was such a nice man yeah he's
probably dead didn't get enough
spaghetti in a can if you ask me okay so
oh why is there just a lonely chair up
[ __ ] aisle by the shore over here oh
[ __ ]
sorry sorry yeah [ __ ] sorry oh geez I'm
[ __ ] everything up I apologize to
everyone I'm just a goddamn screw-up
that's what I am all right so I don't
think there's anything else over here I
don't have any sort of flashlight so
it's going to be difficult to explore
anyway and I think this was just a back
way into the normal place that I was
going already
so there must be the answer somewhere
over here so I'll be right back once I
figure out the next place I'm supposed
to go
oh hello Oh only use the cargo crane if
you really need it it broke down again
last week and won't operate properly
ever since they told me it's got
something to do with the compressors who
knows I asked the maintenance guys to
take a look at it last time but I guess
they don't have any time to spare these
days they must have been too busy
cleaning up the spills in the mines here
it's been a real mess down there lately
okay so huh-huh okay
whoa Jesus oh yes okay so what that did
use the spacebar to jump okay I get that
but I think don't I need to whoop whoop
whoop whoop whoop whoop haha oh no I
need to go over here okay ha Bisky
there gonna be another bear trap
anywhere over here I'm about to get
blasted in the ass again alrighty then
stop that alright so far so clear
alright runnin warning keep hands clear
from machinery
how about new how about I stick my hands
right in there oh well that didn't do
nothing that did Jack's quaterly dick
danger high voltage no trespassing
danger high voltage oh why would I need
to sprint I always get very weary when
they tell me how to sprint due to recent
events all operations at the monitors
committing the facilities have been
suspended indefinitely local residents
are strongly encouraged to keep a safe
distance until further notice
trespassers will be prosecuted and will
be dealt with harshly you have been
warned
have I now oh goodness I'm gonna go in
anyway because I'm a baller like that
okay so I have a funny feeling I'm
supposed to smash open the gates here at
least that's just my understanding about
how this all works so there's got to be
a way to release this trolley type
device and have a go
slam eBay me into that wall where's the
Slammy baby switch who is it here okay
something over there
and there's something over there and I
would believe and I would believe that
that switch probably releases this thing
and it causes it to go careening forward
but I'll get to that in a second because
I believe there's more to explore down
yonder way so give me two seconds and
I'll go over here into the area where it
said I might need to know how to sprint
hey [ __ ] you what are you doing what are
you what are you you couldn't have come
out of the mines I don't know what you
are Oh alrighty then well fancy wincy
hello Oh God
hello ha [ __ ] off with the stupid bear
traps ow
why they put those there intentionally
because they think I'm stupid and I am
huh be gentle with the steam pressure
oops the cart breaks often get stuck use
the pressure control to set the speed
instead there's a few more days left
anyway the administration ordered the
ceiling of our tunnels next week we're
going home
Mike love Mike okay so there's no
machinery over there what am I gonna
keep my hands clear of okay so I'm
imagining that if I turn these things on
its gonna get steamed to the thing and
then there's guru oh [ __ ]
but something happened it's gonna be
[ __ ] yum-yum-yum-yum-yum there's gonna
be steamed to the thing and there's
danger over here kazoo oh okay
don't touch that weird liquid is bad
okay so but that puts steam over on the
thingy and so now the thing you should
be able to get gone and blast it all the
way to the thing right then that makes
sense probably not here we go God
blowing Wow goddamn holy [ __ ]
this thing had some oomph the thing has
a major ohm flinch okay so follow the
trail of oomph it's in here
and then oh I guess we're going in now
oh boy whoo Nelly
whoo Nelly oh boy oh hello hi big red
button I can't press you okay going
further to out oops sorry okay good then
hi I can't move please okay are you
scanning me can you see me naked right
now
Oh eyes a little bizarre okay
whoo I don't know what I did but it
seemed like it was important in my
clumsy hands probably broke it
alrighty then but that's green but let
me see what's up over here first
probably another bear trap can of food
huh I don't see anything too important
ah okay squeaky eye what's on over here
ah loading screen I should have listened
to the locals they warned me about the
coming storm I barely made it out alive
although the directions the fishermen
gave me were most helpful I completely
lost my bearings in all the chaos
she moved quickly and fine sheltered
before things get any worse yeah into
the mines where every note said about
all the death poisoning alright
III also noticed there's a little like
note counter in the bottom left which
I'm assuming is is for all the notes
that I can find I don't know if I found
all of them in the last one i'ma try to
be very observant but you know me I get
distracted way too easily
oh is that okay how do hello it's me
mark EMU hello
okay ah someone's taking a bath over
there did a big no-no one okay
I actually do wonder if they're ever
gonna give me a lighting type device oh
boy oh boy
also I will admit I love the slow
introduction that this game is giving
like the slow pacing and introduced
introduction to the world it's
definitely nice and I appreciate the
cramped quarters that it's forcing me
into Mike as much as we try to get rid
of these bloody mushrooms they keep
growing back for some unknown reason
this new guy from the offices took
samples down today he's some sort of
doctor he said the mushrooms are toxic
and suggest keeping a safe distance make
sure to use a protective suit if you
venture down into the basement let's not
take any risks well it seems like that
didn't help because apparently everyone
is dead anyway alright so this game also
said that it did have an emphasis on
puzzles which we all know when it comes
to puzzles mark emu is smarty poo oh all
right uh-huh okay so I don't know if
that was supposed to be the last
tutorial
hello ah [ __ ] [ __ ] huh great so happy
about that all right what does that do
put steam on apparently goddamnit we're
never gonna learn look down
not that I'd even be able to see it in
the darkness it's completely pitch black
around here
that sounds bad given my experience with
these types of games I feel like I can
recognize ah I got ya ha ha how am I
supposed to get around that it's
literally drill literally the only
direction to go can I go can I jump over
it probably not yeah okay okay we made
it
alright okay day 330 for the lady living
in the house down the beats came by to
ask for help today it's such a shame her
husband got the sickness too
she's so beautiful I would hate to see
her cry we gave her our last restorative
though it doesn't look like he'll
survive the night maybe you can ease his
pain we won't be needing it anyway thank
God it's just two more days left until
we can leave this damaged place uh-huh
okay [ __ ] it let me at the food
I want my munchies oh boy damn I I feel
like oh I thought that was like a
crouching place that I could go down
into that would have been bad okay
okay we're fine everything's fine okay
that's locked up all right oh that looks
dangerous
is this bad okay it's not deadly water
but probably not ill oh oh god oh god I
just realized I'm just crouching in a
pile of poop oh why there's so many
mushrooms I probably am infected with
the disease now grey
oh boy haha okay what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] off okay who knocked this door down
oh ah yes
lovely lovely all this definitely lovely
yeah oh okay yeah sure okay let go the
right way I don't feel like it I see you
see you all right turned another one on
so I'm just cranking up all these steam
generators around here hopefully they're
gonna lead me to where I need to go okay
okay alright I think I got it alright
hello day 83 the administration
recruited two more locals today good
fellows to Nico's tall grey hair with a
kind look in his eyes and his 14 year
old son Manos three of us were
instructed to stay behind and build
solid walls and patch up the ceiling for
abandoned tunnels I considered that to
be a very honor of quest for this mine I
suspect they may have future plans for
this place yeah like horrifying
experimentation of the worst type
elevator power control up well that [ __ ]
it out okay but that leads back into the
main area where I was before so there
must be another puzzle down here to get
the elevator working which is probably
gonna help me get farther down in the
mine looks like they're out of yellow
goop I need to find a way to get more
yellow goop in here oh this is the
elevator okay so there's probably
something else in this facility that has
all of the yellow goop storage I just
need to get to it oh this doors open now
hello oh it's dark
oh no I've been here okay I've been here
that's the other door for the elevator
control okay so this went through woah
darker than I remember in here did I go
in here maybe maybe not
man I'm already getting turned around
just because I'm not familiar with this
place
okay huh oh that didn't look good that
didn't look good at all
oh those are flies I thought there was
the moans of the Damned
that's the moat of the Damned holy [ __ ]
Wow where do I go who are you
my okay okay what was that
who's that a whole lot of nothing it was
probably nothing
hello nothing hello hit me
okay ah good yes very thumb keys Oh
excellent
Oh Oh like that I don't like that at all
oh geez fuzzy Scoob oh come on don't do
that don't do that don't do that oh okay
this is what you would call bad hmm uh
hello other beartrap
I see you this time fool me six times
shame on you fool me seven shame on me
although time has been sparse recently I
finally made a breakthrough in my study
of the black liquid and as I expected it
as much to offer so far I've been able
to extract an interesting otherworldly
substance it displays incredible
restorative properties when applied to
organic tissue although its effects do
not seem to be permanent I'm kasha leo
booth I am cautiously optimistic that I
will be able to refine the matter into a
form of medicine that I will be able to
administer in a more suitable manner for
the study will shove this true okay what
was this - it doesn't even have a label
on it I can only assume this powered
something good [ __ ] up what the [ __ ] are
you
my friend wanna be friends
I doesn't sound good well then some good
hot [ __ ] up who that oh I'm okay man 90%
of all the scares in this game so far
I've just been me scaring myself like an
idiot which is what I am very much what
is that
what is that consume health supplements
oh man
better than food I suppose like whoa
okay very funky hello
alrighty then uh mo hi oh my god it's
that guy from am near sure towards the
end bum buh
was his name bum buh yeah it was bum buh
good old bum be bum be bum buh good boy
humble humble bumble bumble humble
bumble hello
it me again am i back to where I was
before
Dave 345 I really don't know what we're
still doing here there's no word from
management and no one is answering our
calls on the transmitter we're out of
here as soon as we seal the eastern
tunnel they can all go to hell why not
just run away okay so that's some sort
of saving mechanic of some sort ooh
hello health supplement how are you good
thank you okay I'm assuming they're
giving me these because I'm about to
encounter some anti health people some
anti health devices okay
so this just leads back to
that main room area hi I can do that too
am I good enough to join the choirs of
the Damned okay let's see if the
elevator will power up now ah that's
probably good sounds when the entire
earth shatters okay well I'm off
see you assbags later or I'll probably
just see you in the next area okay the
overly dramatic entrance into the
elevator but that's okay I won't judge
you come on bye forever
sayonara see you later
oh we're just now doing the intro
credits are we oh that was just an
introductory period was it ha ha ha hey
I'm not even gonna try to pronounce that
name
waiter just dawned on me that name was
Stefan ooh Stefan Oh
oh boy man I think these names are Greek
I think that's why all the references in
the game are Greek but either way this
is off to a great start a wonderful
start and I can definitely see the
parallels the amnesia and heck maybe the
game was a little bit inspired by it but
I'm not gonna like I said I don't want
to be too heavy-handed about it
Oh oh it lovely oh gosh [ __ ] it's gonna
it's gonna drop me isn't it is it am I
free to go
oh no well there was food and sunlight
Oh God here we go three two one
Kurt young arrogant
oh boy oh [ __ ] here we go and dead
instantly dead that's the end of the
game everyone's dead everyone being me
and all the monsters do they're dead
hopefully oh boy I was sure I'd find
somebody in the mines but all the
tunnels are deserted where is everybody
oh [ __ ] would I know I just got here I
don't know what's happening I have no
idea oh man oh where am I now
oh god I'm greeted by a Skellington mmm
that's good that's a good start okay so
actually I'm gonna end this episode here
this is off to a phenomenal start I mean
even though I've only been scaring
myself it's always a good sign when the
game sets it up so well then I just end
up scaring myself because I'm so
paranoid about the environment and this
is looking to be a fantastic horror game
I cannot wait to play this and this is
only episode 1 I don't know how long the
episodes are but it looks like it's
going to be a long and very enjoyable
experience so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what your
thoughts in the comment below and as
always I will see you
and next video [ __ ] what did I do
there must be another way ah that's the
stuff oh no no no what the [ __ ]